now we'd like to discuss angular
acceleration for circular motion so
suppose we have our angle theta radius R
and our hat and theta hat recall that we
described the angular velocity as the
derivative of D theta DT and we made
this perpendicular to our right-handed
coordinate system Direction K now let's
differentiate that to get our concept of
angular acceleration so alpha is the
second derivative d theta DT squared K
hat and this quantity is what we call
angular acceleration now we'll describe
the component alpha Z as d squared theta
DT squared so it's the second derivative
of the angle and also if we wrote this
as Omega Z K hat we can write that as
the derivative D Omega Z DT as well so
this is the component and now in
circular motion the quantities of Omega
and alpha Z are very much like the
linear quantities of the X component of
the velocity in the X component of the
acceleration and again when we've chosen
a reference frame let's look at what
various components mean let's begin with
the case one where Omega Z is positive
so when Omega Z is positive that tells
us that the angle d theta/dt is
increasing and that corresponds to
counter clockwise motion now given that
case let's look at what happens when
alpha Z is positive remember that's the
statement that D Omega DT is positive
that Omega Z is increasing so if an
object is moving with the positive
component of Omega Z and the angular
acceleration component is positive that
corresponds to increasing the linear
example if
had one dimensional motion I had you had
VX positive and a X positive corresponds
to an object increasing in the its speed
in the X direction that's our first case
now let's look at the second example
when alpha Z is less than zero so now
the derivative of D Omega Z DT is
negative what that corresponds to
remember Omega Z is the Z component of
the angular speed and if that's slowing
down then with alpha Z less than zero
the object is slowing down so in our
linear case if we had a X less than zero
this is the classic example of braking
the object is moving in the X direction
and slowing down now let's look at case
two where this is always a little bit
complicated for circular motion where
Omega Z is less than zero in that case
the object is moving in the clockwise
direction because the angle theta is
decreasing corresponding to clockwise
motion
so in that case once again let's
consider the two examples well the first
example is a positive component of
angular acceleration now this is the one
that can be a little bit confusing the
object is moving clockwise but it has a
positive alpha Z which will correspond
to slowing the object down and if the
Alpha Z remains positive it will
actually come to rest and then reverse
its motion and start to speed up so this
is the case where D Omega is DZ is
increasing and that's our first case so
something like that could correspond to
if we plotted Omega Z and we had an
object that starts off with a negative
Omega Z and increases
notice that the slope here which is
alpha z+ corresponds to a positive
angular acceleration component and the
object slows down as Omega gets closer
to zero stops and now has a positive
Omega Z corresponding to motion in
counterclockwise direction for our
linear case this corresponds to again
with I hat our object moving to the left
the X negative and if a X is positive it
breaks in this direction which means
it's slowing down and then eventually
give it alpha X a X stays positive it
continues in that direction now our
final case and I'll put it down here B
is this is again where Omega Z negative
and alpha Z negative it's always helpful
to see this immediately with the graph
Omega Z is negative here alpha Z which
is the slope is also negative this
corresponds to an object moving in the
clockwise direction and actually its
speed is increasing because alpha Z is
negative so it's going faster and faster
in the clockwise direction even though
alpha Z is negative and for our linear
case again this corresponds to an object
moving in the negative x direction and a
X is negative it's moving faster in the
negative x direction and so these are
the cases of how we analyze the various
component the various cases for angular
acceleration and angular velocity